[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt mal hand aufs herz wer hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu groß
interessiert bevor das corona wie
horoskope sind aufgetaucht ist wer hat
darauf geachtet was die whu macht und
was sie so von sich gibt und wen hat
gross interessiert wer in der whu die
strippen zieht und die welt
gesundheitspolitik kontrolliert ob ihre
agenda überhaupt von demokratisch
legitimierten vertretern bestimmt wird
oder von jemand ganz anderes
nein das hat so gut wie niemanden
interessiert
[Musik]
es musste erst wochen lang 24 stunden am
tag auf allen kanälen nichts anderes
mehr laufen als die große tanne welche
über die ganze welt rollt und millionen
von menschen zu töten droht erst dann
begannen die öffentlichkeit auf das zu
achten was die whu so treibt und sagt ja
wir sprechen hier über den
internationalen maßstab für alles was
mit medizin und gesundheit zu tun hat
politiker können ideologische freien
genommen seien aber die whu setzt sich
doch nur aus objektiven wissenschaftler
zusammen oder dh dass ihre
entscheidungen nicht durch politische
kämpfe motiviert sein sollten sondern
einzig und allein durch eine
evidenzbasierte wissenschaftliche
methodik und ethik nun falls ihr das
wirklich glaubt dann schaut euch mal
folgende meldung an
[Musik]
ein richtiger schritt globalisierung der
traditionellen chinesischen medizin die
traditionelle medizin die ihren ursprung
in der traditionellen chinesischen
medizin kurz tcm hat wurde in die ältere
version der internationalen
klassifikation der krankheiten als cd
aufgenommen was einen wichtigen schritt
zu ihrer internationalisierung darstellt
warum ist diese nachricht so wichtig nun
die internationale statistische
klassifikation der krankheiten icd
genannt ist jedes dokument in dem die
whu die verfahren zur diagnose von
krankheiten holt die behandlungsmethoden
zu deren linderung aufhört ihr inhalt
hat maßgeblichen einfluss auf die
gesundheitspolitik von regierungen auf
der ganzen welt und darauf welche
behandlungsmethoden vom
krankenversicherungen anerkannt und
bezahlt werden mit anderen worten durch
die aufnahme einer behandlungsmethode in
diese klassifikation kann eine
pseudowissenschaft auf das level von
evidenzbasierten methoden der
schulmedizin gehoben werden es ist also
der schlüssel um die gigantischen
geldtöpfe und gesundheitsbudgets und
versicherungen und ganzer staaten
anzutasten und an dieser stelle könnt
ihr euch sicherlich schon vorstellen
welche rolle dabei spielen könnte fakt
ist nämlich dass sich der einfluss
pekings bei der bhu immer stärker
bemerkbar macht ich bin sicher dass
viele von euch inzwischen vom skandal
wie halo im zusammenhang mit taiwan
gehört haben grundsätzlich erkennt die
idee haben nämlich waren nicht als
mitgliedstaat an
sie erkennt es gemäss der diktion
pekings mit mal als eigenständigen staat
an
hallo
und diese art von lobbyismus und
unterwürfigkeit hat nicht nur rein
politische auswirkungen sondern kostet
menschen nehmen das ist ein problem für
alle die zum beispiel gegen das krone
virus kämpfen denn gerade taiwan ist
eines der länder die die tante nie am
besten eindämmen konnte unser ohne
drakonische maßnahmen und eine
entrechtung der bevölkerung nach
chinesischem vorbild die
erfolgsgeschichte thailand ist von
großer bedeutung damit sich anderer
länder an diesem vorbild orientieren
können ohne gleich zu einem weiteren
nord korea oder china zu mutieren china
unternimmt jedoch alles um genau dies zu
verhindern und die whu tanzt hier voll
und ganz nach pegnitz pfeifen
menschenleben sind hier schon gar nicht
so wichtig wie die loyalität zu peek
liegt und ich weiß was einige von euch
jetzt denken könnten schon wieder
scheint sich visual politik bei den amis
ein und zieht china wahllos durch den
dreck von wem werdet ihr bezahlt
wahrscheinlich steht auf der
gehaltsliste von donald trump persönlich
nun nicht wirklich bei den recherchen zu
diesem video haben wir uns die
machtverhältnisse innerhalb der whu
etwas genauer angesehen und wie ihr
sehen wer das sitzen die strippenzieher
der weltgesundheit sowohl in genf als
auch in peking und den usa passt also
gut auf denn natürlich china hat große
verdienste für die ganze welt
vorzuweisen
wir alle erkennen die enormen
wirtschaftlichen fortschritte hier also
an dank china ist unser aller wohlstand
in den vergangenen jahrzehnten gewachsen
und die armut rund um den globus
zurückgegangen zumindest bis zur corona
krise es gibt jedoch viele bereiche in
denen der einfluss und die stark
expansionistische politik pekings sehr
gefährlich werden kann und hier haben
wir ein solches beispiel denkmal eine
sekunde über folgende tatsache macht
wenn jemand einen politiker für seine
politische entscheidung kritisiert wird
dies normalerweise von jedem als freie
meinungsäußerung akzeptiert die whu
jedoch ist eine wissenschaftliche
autorität wir haben keine andere wahl
als allem was
zu vertrauen denn wir selbst sind ja
keine gesundheitsexperten dieses
interview und sagen was sache ist wer
ihre aussagen in zweifel zieht wird
schnell in die ecke der
verschwörungstheoretiker und alu hut
träger abgeschoben die whu ist weltweit
der oberste schiedsrichter im kampf
gegen fake news und ein solcher
schiedsrichter darf keiner ideologie
oder religion zugeneigt sein darf sich
nur auf evidenz basierte methoden und
die prinzipien der wissenschaftspolitik
stützen die frage die wir uns heute
stellen lautet also warum zum teufel hat
die weko die traditionelle chinesische
medizin anerkannt und auf die gleiche
ebene wie evidenzbasierte medizin
gehoben heißt es etwa das tcm am ende
doch gut ist wissenschaftlich fundiert
und in ihrer wirkungsweise klar
nachgewiesen oder steckt vielleicht doch
eine politische agenda hinter diese
anerkennung und wenn ja wie funktioniert
das system whu wer zieht dort an den
fäden wer entscheidet nun konfuzius sagt
einmal versuche nicht die antworten zu
kennen bevor du die fragen verstehst und
deshalb wollen wir bei visual politik
heute diese fragen beantworten bist du
bereit auf ein spannendes abenteuer in
den kommunisten populisten und
milliardäre um die weltherrschaft man
natürlich weltgesundheit kämpfen gut
aber zuerst werden die uns wie immer ein
wenig mit der geschichte beschäftigt
[Musik]
der arzt der welt und sozius sagte auch
studiere die vergangenheit wenn du die
zukunft vorhersagen willst deshalb
werden sie jetzt in das jahr 1948 reisen
in das jahr in dem die whu mit sitz im
schönen genf in der schweiz gegründet
wurde wie so war es damals so wichtig
eine unterorganisation der uno für
gesundheitsfragen zu gründen ich denke
das ist bei der korona pandemie bereits
deutlich geworden
krankheiten verstehen keinen grenzen für
alle sollten allein aus selbstschutz ein
interesse daran haben dass auch der rest
der welt gesund ist aber moment mal denn
ihre rolle beschränkt sich nicht nur auf
pandemien die whu hat zum beispiel auch
wichtige arbeit zur ausweitung von
impfkampagnen geleistet und kampagnen
sind nicht nur eine frage der
humanitären hilfe und nächstenliebe denn
eine für uns unvorstellbare zahl von
menschen in sehr armen ländern können
nicht einfach zum arzt gehen wie wir und
angenommen in eine arme region mit
millionen von menschen wie zb dem kongo
bricht plötzlich eine wieder
[Musik]
dann kann diese auch über die
migrationsströme sehr leicht nach europa
gelangen
tatsächlich kann sich die whu in dieser
hinsicht masse ich auf die schulter
klopfen ihr größter erfolg liegt
allerdings schon lange zurück als 40
jahren die brocken restlos aus der
menschlichen population ausgerottet
wurden ja trocken sind in der tat die
einzige krankheit des menschen die heute
nur noch in labors existiert darüber
hinaus wurden viele andere krankheiten
unter kontrolle gebracht wirklich
schwere krankheiten die früher millionen
von menschen töteten oder verstümmelten
wie zb polio kinderlähmung
sie stellen heute kein großes problem
mehr dar sie könnten aber wieder
aufflammen wenn länder wie afghanistan
oder pakistan die auswertungen nicht
abschließen aus diesem grund erfüllt die
whu drei funktionen quasi als arzt des
ganzen planeten die erste besteht darin
die entwicklungsländer bei der
ausweitung ihrer im kampagnen zu
unterstützen
ich spreche den mutig mitarbeiter des
polo impfstoffs zumeist frauen die sich
für die ausrottung der kinderlähmung in
pakistan einsetzen meine anerkennung aus
es wurden wichtige fortschritte erzielt
aber wir brauchen einen konzertierten
vorstoß um diese schreckliche krankheit
aus worden
antonio guterres un generalsekretär und
in den ersten ländern ist die whu direkt
an der eindämmung von ausbrüchen von
infektionskrankheiten beteiligt
wh unterstützt der anwalt cholera schlug
impf kampagne zur verhinderung des
risikos eines cholera ausbruchs in rang
die zweite funktion besteht darin
ereignis im gesundheitsbereich zu
überwachen um wichtige empfehlungen
auszusprechen die von allen ländern
berücksichtigt werden sollten das sehen
wir in diesen monaten die whu ruft eine
globale pandemie aus und die länder
reagieren darauf schließlich hat dieser
auch noch die aufgabe das internationale
war dem weg um zu pflegen dieses soll
als weltweite referenz dienen als
medizinisches handbuch den man entnehmen
kann welche behandlungsmethoden
unbedingt am end wirksam sind und welche
nicht so gab die whu kürzlich zum
beispiel eine warnung heraus nicht rosa
mine seien potenziell krebserregend und
daraufhin fingen die zulassungsbehörden
in den einzelnen ländern an alle
medikament auch mit rousseff amine hin
zu untersuchen und sie waren sie in
mitteln wie sand hat
[Musik]
us food and drug administration findet
krebserregende verunreinigungen entdeckt
den beliebten medikament gegen
sodbrennen und an dieser stelle sollten
wir vielleicht die frage klären wie
funktioniert die whu eigentlich wie wird
doch entschieden wird dass alles streng
wissenschaftlicher gibt es irgendwelche
demokratisch legitimierten
abstimmungsprozesse wer bestimmt die
agenda der whu schauen wir uns das
machen ein wenig aus der nähe bei der
whu arbeiten ärzte spezialisten für
öffentliche gesundheit wissenschaftler
und epidemiologen aus der ganzen welt
zusammen aber diese gucken nicht den
ganzen tag durch ein mikroskop die
laborarbeit wird von mehr als 700
forschungszentren und universitäten in
etwa 80 ländern geleistet die in ihren
projekten mit der sie hallo zusammen
[Musik]
was die whu tut ist diese informationen
zu koordinieren jetzt werdet ihr sagen
das ist alles schon gut aber wer leidet
die whu wer hat dort das sagen nun das
hängt von der weltgesundheitsversammlung
auch kurz world oder einmal im jahr
lassen sich die vertreter aller
mitgliedsländer der whu in genf und
lassen dort die wichtigsten
entscheidungen der organisation auf der
uk wird der exekutivrat und sein
generaldirektor zurzeit ist dies der
äthiopier petrus a0cayb jesus
jedes mitgliedsland egal ob groß oder
klein hat dabei die gleiche anzahl von
stimmen aber passt mal auf der jetzt
kommt der spannende part viele von euch
fragen sich jetzt vielleicht schon das
ist alles schon gut mag aber wer bezahlt
die ganze chose nun hier wird es
wirklich interessant denn obwohl der
exekutivrat von den mitgliedern gewählt
wird so bestimmt dieser nicht alles was
an der whu läuft denn ein großteil des
budgets der whu ist zweck und projekt
gefunden und für welche zwecke und
projekte diese finanziellen mittel
eingesetzt werden entscheiden
diejenigen welche das geld bereit
stellen die zahl und der zweck der
projekte entscheiden wiederum darüber
wie viele und vor allem welche fachleute
und manager von der whu eingestellt
werden alles in allem kann man also
sagen dass in der eu gilt der zahlt
bestimmt die musik
[Musik]
wenn dem also so ist was meint ihr wer
sollte diese ganzen finanzmittel für die
whu bereitstellen immerhin handelt es
sich um eine organisation welche
maßgeblichen einfluss hat auf die
gesundheitspolitik und medizinische
praxis und mittlerweile im zeitalter des
pandemie horse eigentlich auch auf alles
andere hängt ihr nicht es wäre das beste
wenn eben all diese staaten auf welche
die whu derart einfluss sind die
finanzierung paritätisch übernehmen
würden allein nur um jeglichem verdacht
unberechtigte einflussnahme dritter
auszuschließen
natürlich so was denkt jeder der noch
irgendwie an einen rest des guten und
gerechten in der welt glaubt ja aber
leider leider ihr könnt euch jetzt
sicher schon denken wie die realität
aussieht in den 1970 er jahren war es
tatsächlich noch so dass 80 prozent des
budgets durch die mitgliedstaaten
finanziert wurden und 20 prozent durch
stiftungen und verschiedene industrie
und lobbyorganisationen doch
mittlerweile hat sich dieses verhältnis
umgekehrt im jahr 2016 zum beispiel
kamen nur noch 21 prozent der whu mittel
von den mitgliedstaaten und nur über
diese 21 prozent kann der gewählte
exekutivrat frei verfügen über den
einsatz der restlichen 79 prozent
bestimmen jeweiligen geldgeber
wer aber sind diese mächtigen player nun
zum beispiel privatstiftungen konzern
verbände und andere organisationen den
obersten platz der privat finanziers
belegt die privatstiftung des bill gates
an zweiter stelle folgte im allianz gavi
eine lobbyorganisation in der zum
beispiel pharmakonzern glaxosmithkline
sitzen geld bekommt sie auch von staaten
zweitgrößter geldgeber der gavi ist
jedoch mit 15 6 milliarden dollar wert
die gates-stiftung viele szenen an dem
die whu und in zeiten der pandemie die
ganze welt hängt laufen also
hauptsächlich bei einer privatperson
zusammen welche von niemandem die
demokratisch gewählt wurde nun aber
maßgeblich das leben aller menschen
beeinflusst was soll man davon halten
schaut die gates stiftung hat einerseits
viel geleistet im hinblick auf die
impfung von menschen in ländern der
dritten welt dieser arbeit ist sehr
wichtig viele schwere krankheiten welche
in diesen ländern für einen kreislauf
aus armut und elend verantwortlich sind
können nicht anders als mit
flächendeckenden in programmen
ausgerottet werden dadurch steigt der
lebensstandard der menschen in diesen
ländern es gibt weniger arbeitslosigkeit
überbevölkerung kriminalität und kriege
diese menschen haben dann auch weniger
gründe aus ihren ländern zu migrieren
das sind alles unterstützende für diesen
des bill gates andererseits erinnert
sich manch einer an bill gates
vergangenheit als knallharter
geschäftsmann dessen firma microsoft
geschaltete mitbewerber mit guten
geschäftspraktiken die lust und
verunsicherung kampagnen aus um ein
monopol zu errichten viele sahen den
konzern deswegen als das reich des bösen
an
denn das alles führte dazu dass die
anwender am ende keine andere wahl
hatten als das betriebssystem windows zu
lassen welches unter kritikern als
instabile virenschleuder galt
[Applaus]
manche menschen liegen deswegen auch
heute ein gewisses misstrauen dagegen
dass gates sein vermögen nun dazu
einsetzt seine agenda im
gesundheitswesen weltweit voranzutreiben
vor allem wenn er positive ziele mit
weiteren forderungen verbindet mit
forderungen zur einschränkung von
grundrechten und mit einer groß
angelegten digitalen überwachung aller
menschen zur durchsetzung einer
allgemeinen dienstpflicht denn für die
implementierung globaler
überwachungsmaßnahme stehen seine firmen
bereits mit fertigen konzepten
gewährleistet ob alle diese bedenken zu
treffen haben wir zu diesem zeitpunkt
auch nicht sagen aber wir wissen dass
man sehr wachsam sein muss vor allem in
zeiten des umbruchs werde starke führer
von menschen verlangen dass sie die
kontrolle über ihr leben und ihre
freiheitsrechte in deren hände legen da
ansonsten millionen von menschen sterben
müssten aber dies ist ein sehr
umfangreiches und wichtiges thema das
der es uns lieber für ein zukünftiges
video auf sparen wollen
[Musik]
in einem früheren video haben bereits
beispielhaft dargelegt wie das
kommunistische regime chinas die korona
krise missbraucht hat um seine macht in
hongkong auszuweiten ihr könnt euch
dieses video ansehen indem er auf den
link klickt er jetzt oben erscheint oder
in der beschreibung unter diesem video
steht schließlich handelt es sich bei
der bh aber auch um ein wirklich
anschauliches beispiel dafür wie sehr
sich die öffentlichkeit auch irren kann
er auf der welt das sagen hat denn im
falle der whu sieht es zwar nach außen
so aus als ob der von den
mitgliedstaaten gewählte exekutivrat
aussagen hätte die macht im endeffekt
also von dir mir uns allen also den wlan
demokratischer regierungen ausgehen aber
wie wir soeben gesehen haben entspricht
dies nur zu 21 prozent der wahrheit
79 prozent der macht geht von anderen
aus nicht von dir und von mir auch nicht
nun aber betritt als heldenhafter retter
in dieser düsteren situation welche
große mann die bühne donald trump
erinnert ihr euch noch an america first
einige von euch werden vielleicht denken
dass das ein lehrer slogan war aber weit
gefehlt denn donald trump war schon
immer ein großer kritiker internationale
organisationen was wir da also tun wird
er die whu wieder in demokratischer
hände zurückführen nun schaut selbst
[Musik]
36 finanzierung der
weltgesundheitsorganisation aus die usa
deren refinanzierung der whu stoppen
nachdem donnerstag ein schweres
missmanagement der carola die rustemi
vorgeworfen hatte auf den ersten blick
mag es als sinnvoll erscheinen das jump
die whu unter druck setzt aber kann er
durch die kürzung oder gar das streichen
von mitteln reformen erst wegen zweifel
daran sind angebracht denn wie wir
vorhin gelernt haben sind es die
geldgeber welche die whu steuern und sie
können über die whu mittlerweile derart
viel macht auf der ganzen welt aus das
ist mit dem teufel zugehen müsste wenn
sich nicht sofort mehrere
zahlungskräftige kandidaten finden
würden welche mit freude die durch tom
verursachte finanzierungslücke schließen
und damit ihren einfluss vermehren
wollen damit nun wollen wir euch den
zweiten großen player vorstellen der die
geschicke der whu bestimmt wer steht nun
als topkandidat zur rettung der whu
bereits natürlich china also
ironischerweise genau jenes land den die
welt die jüngste und wohl auch noch so
man sich zukünftige pandemie zu
verdanken hat einer der euch noch an das
video in dem wir das marode chinesische
gesundheitssystem auseinander genommen
und als top- gefahrenquelle neuer
pandemien identifiziert haben
falls nicht könnt ihr es euch wie immer
über den oben oder in der beschreibung
und video ansehen und wenn ihr damals
schon geschockt waren welche gefahren
von traditioneller chinesischer medizin
kurz tcm für die weltgesundheit ausgehen
können dann hört euch erst mal an was
jetzt kommt
[Musik]
wissenschaftlichkeit konfuzius sagte
einmal lernen ohne zu denken ist alte
denken oder zu lernen gefährlich und ihr
wisst dass tradition mehr auf
wiederholung als auf lernen wird einige
scharfe zungen behaupten gar rezession
sei nichts anderes als gruppenzwang den
tote auf leben draußen würden aber die
am toten die können doch nicht so gut
wie wir euch in erwähnten video erklärt
haben existieren im gesundheitssystem
chinas evidenzbasiert und traditionelle
medizin nebeneinander die traditionelle
chinesische medizin beruht auf dem
glauben an die lebensenergie die durch
körper kanäle die meridiane genannt
werden zirkuliert
gesundheitsprobleme werden als
ungleichgewicht im qualifizierten dass
die traditionelle chinesische medizin
versucht dieses gleichgewicht durch
verschiedene heilmittel und therapien
geschaffen und akupunktur
wiederherzustellen
an dieser stelle wird aber vielleicht
jemand einwenden mag du alter
materialistische euro centrica
was ist schlecht daran diesen
naturheilmitteln zu vertrauen nun lasst
uns ein wenig über philosophie wie
dallas und wissenschaftliche methodik
sprechen
[Musik]
schaut wissenschaft und residenz haben
nichts neues zu tun arzneimittel
pauschal nach ihrer herkunft zu
verurteilen wissenschaftlich orientierte
medizin stützt sich nur auf zwei soll
reproduzierbarkeit und falsifiziert
arbeit mit anderen worten eine sache
gilt nicht deswegen als wissenschaftlich
und wissenschaftlich oder
pseudowissenschaftlich nur weil ein
europäischer oder amerikanischer
wissenschaftler das so sagt nein
wissenschaftlichkeit ist gegeben wenn
diese durchaus logischen und objektive
prämissen erfüllt sind ich werde euch
das ganze an einem beispiel erläutern
der geschichte von aspirin viele
jahrhunderte vielleicht jahrtausende
lang bereiteten sowohl die ägypter als
auch einige stämme in amerika aufgüsse
aus weidenrinde um ihre kopfschmerzen
zylinder im jahr 1763 führte ein
wissenschaftler haben uns etwas zutrauen
ein experiment mit patienten durch sie
alle hatten kopfschmerzen er gab ihnen
infusionen aus weiteren extrakt und
befragte sie dann ob die schmerzen
besser geworden sein das heißt das
ergebnis konnte nach objektiven
kriterien beurteilt werden tutmann
kopfweh oder nicht da ist es wichtig
über solche banalitäten zu reden denn
oft finden wir nachrichten in denen es
heißt studie bestätigt dass schokolade
glücklich gemacht und mir leid aber
glück ist etwas was doch wesentlich
subjektive ist als kopfschmerzen aber
damit ist die geschichte noch nicht zu
ende jahre später führten andere
wissenschaftler ähnliche experimente
durch sie ergänzt sie durch blindtest
das heißt eine zweite gruppe mit
menschen die kopfschmerzen hatte aber
höher wasser verabreicht bekam ohne ihr
dies zu sagen es wurde also zusätzlich
geprüft ob der weidenrinde extrakt eine
höhere wirksamkeit aufweist als ein
wirkstoffloses placebo und all diese
experimente hatten die gleichen
ergebnisse das heißt es handelte sich um
eine reproduzierbare experiment es
spielt keine rolle ob die patienten aus
new york oder in münchen kommen in allen
fällen nimmt die beiden sind die
kopfschmerzen und zwar näher als ein
placebo das heißt ein mittel das allein
durch die einbildungskraft der patientin
wird nach langer forschung fanden die
wissenschaftler heraus welcher stoff
genau in der weidenrinde für die
schmerzlindernde wirkung verantwortlich
war und sie isolierten diesen wirkstoff
es war die berühmte us to sally teure
schließlich fanden die chemiker felix
hoffmann und artenreichen grün die für
bayer
weiterhin einen weg also typische euro
synthetisch das heißt nicht durch
extraktion aus pflanzen sondern durch
einen prozess von chemischen reaktionen
aus basischemikalien zu gewinnen und so
wurde aspirin geboren der wirkstoff von
aspirin konnte es zunächst auch als
pflanzlich oder natürlich beworben
werden als er dann aber synthetisch
eingestellt wurde änderte dies ein gar
nichts an seiner wirkung mit anderen
worten wissenschaft ist nicht gegen ihr
ohne wissenschaft würden wir auch heute
noch an viele unvorstellbar schlimmen
krankheiten bleiben deswegen möchte ich
euch heute auf ein projekt der stanford
university hinweisen bei dem wir alle
helfen können das khroma virus aber auch
viele andere krankheiten in zukunft
besser zu verstehen und zu bekämpfen es
handelt sich um das projekt folding home
bei dem ihr wissenschaftlern dabei helft
molekular dass das ist so simulieren und
damit zum beispiel bessere medikamente
zu entwickeln indem ihr diesen die
rechenpower eures computers zur
verfügung stellt den link zum projekt
findet ihr in der beschreibung unter
diesem video und auch methoden der
traditionellen chinesischen medizin
können auf wissenschaftlichen weg
validiert werden zum beispiel eine die
chinesische wissenschaftler antonio 2015
den nobelpreis für medizin zu ihrer
entdeckung dass artemisinin ein
klassisches heilmittel wirksam gegen
malaria hilft in diesem fall sprechen
wir nicht mehr vor traditionen sondern
von evidenz denn die wirkung konnte
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen werden wir
müssen also nicht mehr nur daran glauben
wir wissen jetzt werdet ihr sagen wo
also liegt das problem mit der tcm ganz
einfach es liegt darin dass die meisten
ihrer behandlungsmethoden eben nicht
wissenschaftlich fundiert sind
es gibt zum beispiel leute die idee
einnehmen ein gelee das ausgekochte esel
haut gewonnen wird sie behaupten es
helfe gegen anämie und würde krebs
vorbeugen aber bisher ist es nicht
gelungen diese wirkung nachzuweisen das
einzige argument ist eine 4000 jahre
alte tradition aber das ist nicht das
schlimmste beispiel in vielen fällen
kann eine solche behandlung wirklich
gefährlich werden und wir sprechen nicht
nur von tieren deren erreger auf den
menschen übergehen können denn nicht
alles aus der natur ist gut
studie zeigt dass 90 prozent der
traditionellen chinesischen medizin
spuren giftiger substanzen enthalten
jetzt werden natürlich sofort ein paar
leute einwenden das alles ist doch nur
von big pharma gestreute propaganda nun
big pharma sind nicht die einzigen die
einen haufen geld scheffeln wollen markt
mit traditioneller chinesischer medizin
überschreitet mit land erwartete whu
zulassung umsatz von 50 milliarden
dollar
denn auch wenn sich der begriff
traditionelle medizin schön romantisch
anhört handelt es sich schon lange nicht
um ein paar heiler mit langen weißen
bärten die das durch ihre ahnen von
generationen zu generationen
überlieferte wissen anwenden
allein in china gibt es ganze 4000
krankenhäuser für tcm und die darin
verabreichten mittel müssen in riesigen
industrie komplexen mit tcm fabriken
hergestellt werden und bic tcm will big
pharma natürlich auch nicht alle corona
zu überlassen sondern ordentlich mit
abstaubt
traditionelle chinesische medizin
gewinnen in afrika vor dem hintergrund
des kit 19 ausbruchs an popularität
genau erinnert ihr euch noch an das
projekt one welt von roth die neue
seidenstraße
das risiko ist strukturen ist dass china
mit der welt verbinden soll
nun wird euch mal folgendes paprika wird
zum besten kunden von traditioneller
chinesischer medizin das ist für die tcm
doch schon mal ein großer meilenstein
zur welt
doch ein entscheidender baustein zur
weltherrschaft fehlt ihr noch denn
bisher galt die tcm überall außerhalb
chinas als pseudowissenschaft das heißt
ihre anwendung markt zwar legal seien
aber erste dürfen sie nicht als
gleichwertig mit wissenschaftlichen
orientierte medizin empfehlen und
krankenversicherungen zögern ihren
milliarden töpfe für sich zu öffnen
es ist so als wenn man yoga machen will
schiffe dich viel spaß dabei du kriegst
vielleicht einen kleinen zuschuss von
der krankenkasse aber damit ist keine
reibach zu machen
tja und wer ist die weltweite autorität
welche darüber entscheidet was als
gleichwertig mit wissenschaftlich
orientierte medizin anzuerkennen ist
genau die whu der chinesische einfluss
und fuß hat mal gesagt der mann der den
berg ab trug war derselbe anfingen
kleine steine weg zu tragen und wer ist
für china dieser man genau steht roßtal
umgebe jesus generaldirektor der bhu
wer schlägt partnerschaften mit china
entlang der seidenstraße vor angesichts
des von trump hinterlassen vakuums ist
es nun china das zusammen mit bill gates
zu den stärksten einfluss nehmen der bhu
aufsteigen wird tatsächlich war es
peking das bei der letzten
weltgesundheitsversammlung die fäden
gezogen hat um zetros zum neuen
generaldirektor zu machen und dies hat
sich für die chinesischen kommunisten
dreist ausgezahlt so ein erkennt die whu
wie wir bereits gesagt haben taiwan
nicht als unabhängigen staat an mehr
noch taiwan und seine erfolg im kampf
gegen coop 19 werden von der whu
ignoriert das ist brandgefährlich man
merkt dass sogar hochrangige
wissenschaftler sehr große angst haben
müssen über dieses thema zu sprechen
aber es geht nicht darum dass corona
virus denn der haupt beweis für den
chinesischen einfluss auf die whu ist
ihre adelung der pseudo wissenschaft tcm
ein großer schritt für die traditionelle
chinesische medizin auf dem weg zur
globalisierung und er glaubt dehoga
trotzdem irgendwelche wissenschaftlich
fundierten und gründe dafür haben muss
sich nur mal ihre argumentation allein
die whu begründet ihren schritt damit
dass sich alle länder nun mal nicht die
ausrüstung und behandlungsmethoden der
wissenschaftlich orientierte medizin
leisten können und daher wenigstens auf
die tcm zurückgreifen sollten ich weiß
nicht was ihr von diesem ansatz haltet
aber ich denke wenn man keine
wissenschaftlich fundierten beweise hat
ist es so als hätte man gar kein medizin
denn es gibt im grunde nicht mehrere
mediziner das wort gibt es noch nicht
mal es gibt nur eine medizin und in der
sind all die methoden mittel versammelt
deren wirkung nachgewiesen werden kann
und das ist etwas was nicht du ich sage
die europäische akademie der
wissenschaften und medizin fordert
evidenz basierte diagnostik und
therapien als reaktion auf die aufnahme
der traditionellen chinesischen medizin
in das standard klassifikationssystem
der whu die whu lässt sich jedoch nicht
wurscht europäische wissenschaftler
davon abhalten treu ihren chinesischen
folgen zu folgen die aufnahme der tcm
mit ihr warm wird 2022 realität werden
es ist noch nicht klar welche art von
therapien und behandlungen einbezogen
werden sollen wir wissen noch nicht ob
wir uns schon auf vom hausarzt
verschiedene und für unsere kasse
bezahlte leckere fledermaus note freuen
können oder auch bittere extrakte
ausgekleidet
man kann aber sagen dass diese
entscheidung der whu eine ernsthafte
gefahr für die öffentliche gesundheit
darstellen können denn grünes licht für
die tcm von einer derart wichtigen und
angesehenen weltinstitutionen wiederum
stellt auch in anderen bereichen ein
größeres risiko dar als sie vielleicht
denken was auf
[Musik]
das traditionelle chinesische medizin
und was kann man mit ihr behandeln da
merkt ihr was plötzlich schenkt eines
seriösen angesehene zeitschrift wie das
volksmehr gesehen den methoden der tcm
ihre volle aufmerksamkeit als ob ihre
wirkung bewiesen der stellt euch jetzt
vor was in all den vielen anderen medien
die der wehr urvertrauen geschehen wird
sie werden die tcm ebenso valide halten
die wissenschaftlich orientierte medizin
sie werden ihr in artikeln und sendungen
ebenso viel platz einräumen und die
leser und zuschauer diese an medien
werden nicht einzeln überprüfen was
eventuell führen könnte und was böse ist
denn sie werden sicher keine
wissenschaftlichen studien dass wir
einziehen und bücher wälzen sie werden
diesen medien genauso vertrauen wie
diese medien der whu vertrauen eine
lawine der pseudo wissenschaft wird
dadurch in gang gesetzt und dies wird
nicht nur die traditionellen wir hier
betreffen sondern auch diese plattform
youtube wie andere plattformen kämpft
auch youtube beständig gegen fake news
und euch ist bestimmt nicht entgangen
dass google und youtube in der kroner
krise angefangen haben zu jedem inhalt
jeder suchanfrage und jedem video das
mit dem kroner wir es zu tun haben
könnte eine spezielle stark
hervorgehobene infobox mit links zu
diesem thema einzublenden diese links
führen auf die seiten der bh und dass
sie zunächst einmal nach einer guten
sache aus denn dank dieser infos hat
youtube sicher viele menschen davon
abgehalten viel unsinn zu glauben wie zb
das bleichmittel oder alkohol gegen das
corona virus helfen könnten aber das
ganze birgt ein risiko
die whu ist einer jener schiedsrichter
die darüber entscheiden was wahr ist und
was nicht stellt euch also vor was
passieren kann wenn die tcm von der whu
anerkannt wird dieses video könnte dann
automatisch als techno klassifiziert
werden und in der zwischenzeit würde ein
youtuber der verspricht krebs mit gecko
pulver heil so können die volle
aufmerksamkeit der social media
plattformen erhalten also wie konfuzius
sagen würde das recht zu sehen und
nichts zu tun ist ein mangel an mut und
prinzipien deswegen stellt sich für euch
ist die frage welche rolle wird dieser
meinung nach nach der korona krise in
der welt spielen glaubt ihr dass die tcm
international expandieren kann und der
medizin startet konkurrenz machen wird
wie könnte man die nach strukturen
innerhalb der dh oder
wählen damit diese institution wieder
demokratisch kontrolliert wird wie immer
freuen wir uns schon auf eurer kluge
antworten und eine anregende debatte im
kommentarbereich und wenn ihr keines
unserer aktuellen updates verpassen
wollt abonniert bitte visual politik und
drückt auch die klingelt fast immer
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden
wenn euch dieses video etwas gebracht
hat dann gibt uns einen daumen hoch bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]